good morning Millennials
welcome to the Millennial morning show
the morning toast hosted by Jackie RI
and Taylor Swift's best friend
I can't even like shoot the [ __ ] I just
need to talk about like what happened to
me yesterday because my life like I
literally I'm not okay like I don't even
know like how to put into words the
gratitude that I feel towards Miss
Taylor Alison Swift
and yesterday was just a culmination of
all that because as you guys know I've
been on this Taylor Train like for years
really increasing my Taylor stand ISM in
the past year so and it really comes
from a genuine place of like loving
Taylor but also part of it it's like I
just want to be recognized by I think it
started like a little thirsty but then
it really turned into a true love no no
no Abbot AIT's the opposite like I
really just like fell I've always been
in love with Taylor and like just
looking like just I love her and then
like seeing all these other like people
getting recognized for their Taylor hood
I'm like okay I wanted to know I think
you always have been a fan but then you
saw like reputation room it's like you
have to be the most outspoken fan so you
became that and now that you are that
you really embody you know build
elemental 30 left and just that's it
okay I was here we were all here so um
yesterday was just like a difficult day
because we were travelling and it was
Father's Day and we don't have a dad and
I was just like it was hitting me more
yesterday than ever before same and like
I usually the day goes by and like I
don't think anything I but I'm not great
I don't have to do like some [ __ ]
family activity but like yesterday I was
really feeling like upset and lonely and
I got home and I had so many packages
and my apartment was just like there was
stuff everywhere and I just like I
really didn't want to handle it and I
had to try and dress this for Jackson
Barney's quail egg which just didn't go
well you saw the pictures and it was not
good and I got this box and I just like
opened it up it was from a PR company
and it's like all this Taylor merch and
I'm so confused because I ordered new
Taylor Burch like two days ago and I'm
like there's no way that I got here on a
Sunday and I was so confused and it's me
merch and that's like older merch that I
already got and I'm like what the [ __ ]
and then there's a note and it's like
like a rainbow with all of the colors
stay awesome love Taylor and I was like
so confused because like I didn't
explicitly say
hey you're special you know and that's
just really what I needed yeah and then
the more I looked into it it made me
realize that I was special but it was
from her publicist it was a letter that
signed Taylor and it was six March in my
sighs interests aunt question though was
it the same packaging as when you bought
merch because the box that you took a
picture of looks like the same Mack said
I saw like Becca Tilly get and yeah yeah
yeah I don't remember if it was the same
like when you got your me merge
counselor snitch did it have hearts and
a letter that said stay awesome I didn't
get me merch oh I did it didn't have
hearts but it didn't have that letter
okay so then I saw a lot of people in
the studious 50s helped me they shared
pictures of what Becca Tilly and Tanya
Brad got and it was the same exact okay
so I'm in the moat with Tanya riding
Becca Tilly I just feel like mine's like
a little bit more special I don't know
why I like it's not but it just feel
like it is and like now I'm over here
just like being recognized by Taylor
Swift and like I just don't know what I
did to receive this great honor let me
tell you i watch the past year of
episodes but see that's what I'm saying
that's what was it that caught her eye I
don't know if it was all the episodes if
it was his teenage fifties it was my
tumblr or I just recently posted that
video of me dancing to me on my
Instagram like that was probably true so
well I think I would like to think is
the steamy striptease that caught her
eye I do believe it was the post on
lunch yeah I would like to believe it
was swifty with no job that caught her
eye I mean that would be like my dream
upon dream Susie but those I've has been
slacking a little bit
she's back on but like you know what I
found somebody [ __ ] Instagram
accounts like I don't have time either
yeah grunge grunge the morning toast
swifting with no job my Finn stop like I
can't you know since that yeah my
thinkin stuff you post a lot no it's my
pencil that I used to stuff people oh oh
oh I thought you meant like a thing so
where you post like selfies with your
friend no no I like the car - Kylie and
Kendall do yes I just caught up on
keeping up like the past five episodes
yesterday so I saw that they were
talking about Vince's that Kendall and
Kylie Evan and I was trying to find it
and I couldn't I kind of want to fin
stuff but then offence to where you know
you just post pictures that are not
edited or whatever but that's just like
it would be so difficult for me and it
would turn into just another account for
myself no I have no interest
oh but I had an idea now that I have
this box from Taylor idler haven't taken
anything out of the box because I'm just
so excited about it there's a return
label what if we sent her
some toast Marge oh that be cute yeah
like the box will probably return to
sender but whatever okay I'm down okay
sweet well welcome to Monday morning
everyone what a sad day what a sense and
sadder than the day after vacation we
vacation this weekend in Palm Beach we
did a couple podcast episodes last week
so we used our new fancy interface our
integrated interface it's an integrated
interface feel free to head over to the
podcast app we had three new episodes
last week that were really premium I
tried Tim Hortons live yeah they were
really premium yeah what are you overall
thoughts on Tim Hortons apparently you
didn't get the best flavors the birthday
cake yeah I know well that would be the
PAS job to go and get sorry that's like
nobody told me anything I just went that
was like hey Tim bits and that's what I
got rang a microphone
yesterday weird okay good we want to
hear everything have to say counselor
so the Tim it's were really good like
they're munchkins um they're the same
exact thing except they served one
horrendous flavor that we obviously
banned here in the US because it was so
vile and disgusting I could have thrown
up I thought it was lemon then someone
told me was probably maple regardless
irregardless just not for me understood
well we have so much to talk about today
all the news that happen while we were
gone so many shows to recap Mahoney the
greatest episode of all time of all time
southern charm Keeping Up with the
Kardashians Beverly Hills I got all my
television yesterday on the play and I
love using airplane time to be
productive now I know you don't know
what that's like because you have the
ability to fall asleep before takeoff
and wake up after landing and not all of
us could be that lucky so I have to use
it for for productivity and that's what
I did I watched southern charm in New
York and Beverly Hills and it really
made the flight fly no I'm the way there
I didn't sleep the whole time and I
watched the black mayor Miley episode
and it was really good I liked the the
new three black mayor episodes I watched
another one last night are less scary
and creepy and disgusting than they
stand in years past like where the Prime
Minister is backing a pig oh my god yeah
like next show was good for me I think
about that thing all the time when like
they found out that and he was doing it
for an hour too long like truly just
kill me like taking God and kill me
because I just [ __ ] care that was
evil and I'll never forgive Netflix for
doing that to me thank you for inviting
me
yeah but my Lea
so it's really fun the sug is good and
it's not scared like I was scared to
watch it alone
but I watched Mountain planing it was
fine so ok that's recap we have you need
to calm down
to recap so much happen today this
morning I've been up for hours
so I think I'm not sure you think I big
do you think counselor snitch what do
you think do you think it's time oh I
think it's time yeah I think it's time
to deliver fast five stories that you
need to know before you wake up and take
a bite out of your morning toast but
before we do that please let me let you
guys know it would be my honor to let
you know that I know that today's
episode is brought to you by thrive
market an online marketplace on a
mission to make healthy living easy and
affordable for everyone they offer the
highest quality healthy and sustainable
products available for every budget
lifestyle and geography you can shop for
thousands of the best selling organic
foods and natural products for
twenty-five to fifty percent below
traditional retail prices it's all
stripped shipped straight to your door
they sell non-gmo food snacks vitamins
supplements personal care products
eco-friendly cleaning supplies safe and
non-toxic beauty products kitchen
staples home goods organic baby food
kids products and much much more thrive
markets prices are already twenty five
to fifty percent off and now they're
giving you an extra 25% off your first
order plus a fifty a free 30-day trial
many of you will be making a grocery run
this week so why not give thrive market
a try from your home if you go to thrive
market calm / toast you're already
getting twenty-five to fifty percent off
and they're gonna give you additional
twenty five percent off your first order
plus free 30-day trial again that's
thrive market calm / toast love it
okay now let's get back into what well
you're already talking about Taylor
Swift hugs it out with Katy Perry and
star studded you need to come down music
video okay while we were gone it all
started with first in iTunes leaked then
a live stream then a song and today a
music video at 8:15 a.m. raise your hand
if you woke up to watch it I did you
know what cuz I said an alarm for 8:15
and I literally like the coincidence or
four it was just I usually do 8:30 so I
just at 8:15
for the video but interestingly enough
it's like I slept last night so poorly
like the way that I used to sleep before
that SAT it's like when you think you
missed it so welcome to 5 7 & 8 15
because I thought I missed the video
like I need to chill out but now the
I've become like a certified tailor
friends like I need to be so supportive
and like be awake on time
totally that was nice of her to put it
out before the toast I feel as though
for that reason like she knew we need to
talk about it today and I appreciate you
know I'm just like time and time again
feeling so seen by Taylor Swift let's
start from the beginning though because
we have an album title we have album
artwork we have a lot more clues
thoughts on lover so on Thursday she
went live told us the album's called
lover Friday sorry the album's called
lover the album cover was released it's
a computer fellini moment with a heart
around her eye and the first a second
signal you need to calm down now I'm not
gonna lie when I heard the name of the
song and I heard it obviously before
because the CDs fifties figure this out
a long time ago um I was like oh God
like the way that you need to calm down
just like looks I'm like oh my god what
is she doing like I don't know and it's
kind of the same way I felt about me
with the exclamation point I'm like what
is it but and I just like had a bad
feeling about it and then it came out
I'm like oh it's everything you know
like shame never made anybody like a
snakes and stones never broke my bones
like truly it really gave me like an
ariana grande thank you next guy because
she's like speak singing almost rapping
and I'm just gonna for you know the
continuous evolution of Taylor Swift's
musical discography yeah so you loved
the song I loved the song man Margaret
listy like better than me uh yeah uh I
don't know they're so different which is
great because I love a you know a
diverse gal me is really more like pop
anthem like singing vibe and I see me in
the club singing you need to calm down
you know what I mean because yeah it's
more of like a point in saying like hey
you know and me it's like me arms in the
air swing you know it just gives me
different tenses which it's great
because they love a diverse discography
understood what are your thoughts
counselor's name I love the song and
like when I listen to it I'm like oh my
god I love this and then me comes on
afterwards and like I'm just like oh my
god I [ __ ] love this song so I think
that's pray tell that I like me better
but I still really just like used to
maybe yeah it might be but I know all
the words it's fun to sing along right
but I really liked me like people like
you just relate to me I like me more
because I agree it's just more and
somatic yeah uh but I love this song to
I mean I just need to leave a little on
early and
in Chinese just in business it's so hard
trying to learn that line about
self-expression I know I'm not trying to
mess with you self-expression but I've
been another lion and obsess about
somebody yes it's no fun that was close
it's really [ __ ] hard yeah you need
to calm down all right now let's talk
about all the the things inside the song
before the video that people are
obsessed with one her multiple use of
pronouns please don't step on my gown
please don't step on his gown please
don't say about our gowns so just like
representation for all pronouns - oh
excuse me I just spit all over myself oh
my god sorry Taylor okay - she'd never
made anybody that's less gay and I love
that line but my sister Jackie did make
an amazing point that I can't stop
thinking about I can't stop thinking
about it either I think the UM the line
would have been even more powerful if it
was hate never made anybody less gay
because I feel as though there's a lot
more hate against the LGBT community
then she and also her song is directly a
Chara sing like the haters but I think
she was just like the song is still
positive but it does address like
something really sad so she was just
trying to make it like light and fluffy
like you know make something negative
into a positive so I think hate is that
kind of a harsh word actually like the
sentence before uses hate she uses the
word hate obvi she don't want to use at
one but she could have changed that
sentence like she's go there assist yeah
you know I just like because people
think that their hate is gonna solve all
the problem all their problems and it's
not gonna make anybody less gay yeah and
it's not no it's truly not so that was
my only like note for her so then I
really wanted to talk about this article
that I read from Vice which the last
article I read from vice was a photo
gallery of people having sex on their
periods and it was just at that moment
that I figured I was done with my yeah
you're just like not their target
audience no and honestly it was really
interesting but I didn't consider it to
be like art I mean I actually I don't
understand why you wouldn't consider
that but I'll respect your opinion oh
really
and actually that's true like it is art
but it's just not like I feel as though
like maybe it's not for you but it's for
a lot of us you think yeah I thought
you did okay whatever I just like I feel
like me and vice is just like not on the
same page these days and then I read
this article by this girl who like
literally makes living off of hating
Taylor Swift apparently she's just like
the go-to journalist who hates Taylor um
and she was just talking about how like
the corporate exploitation of pride is
like a real issue now and like Taylor's
super problematic and and they believe
the girl who wrote it was gay so like
she was just making a lot of points from
her perspective and like I wasn't hating
on it
I disagreed with everything she said but
it was like a really eloquent
way of disagreeing with someone until
she was just like and then at the end
she just threw in and you know there's a
lot of rumors going around that this
entire album or video is Taylor coming
out as bisexual and I just feel like if
she's a member or not and then I was
like you just debunked everything you
said because while you were making a lot
of valid points you just like
potentially outed someone I'm like a
major media platform which is just like
not cool like when people do it on
reddit okay like on a prestigious media
outlet I just don't think that's cool so
I just wanted to say that I thought of a
good point and I wanted to share it
awesome another good point from Hannah
Lou play there's so much spam but I have
to get to this guy shade is a double
meaning shade like hate and shade like
hiding in the closet oh thank you happy
Tuesday
oh that does make a lot more sense and I
haven't read any articles yet and
especially with the video of like all
the extra meat like I've just been like
listening and I really read everything
like pretty surface I'm not like great
at picking up the hit Easter eggs I'm
not you know so versed in the Taylor
dictionary where's code of Taylor but I
look for it sadly but I look forward to
reading one of those articles let's talk
about the video because that's where the
hidden messages really come to like okay
first of all the before like the first
minute of the video before all the cameo
started it was just like a classic
telling music video of her like in this
like clean II asked trailer park and I
just loved it like I just loved Taylor's
aesthetic I feel like she really is
likes teeny she's definitely seen and
she's definitely pleading and there's no
other way to be you know that framed
thing doesn't enjoy being please know
nobody that framed photo on her wall
that says mom I am a rich man like just
you know nodding - you know her Papa
predecessors and then also becoming the
pop star of the future you know it's
just really it's beautiful it's
beautiful I like the
oh I liked the whole trailer park vibe
me too
it was definitely the same trailer
different Park yeah I yeah uh and she
looks great and I
I enjoyed it I loved all the cameos
think that's like it's just that I did
you see todrick was a producer I thought
that was wildly interest that was wildly
in tune because nobody makes a video
like todrick nobody makes a video like
todrick nobody's more in tune with their
like community than todrick and I just
think todrick is such a good friend for
Taylor I feel like he teaches her a lot
you know cuz he grew up so differently
that I really feel like todrick has been
like a great influence and Taylor's life
and I love that she's giving him the
respect he deserves that means he made
coin off the music video so good look
you're making because like it's a hosta
yeah
go forth it it's similar so you know
particularly oh and we have the album to
eat August 23rd 23rd 8th to 3/8 plus
about 2 plus 3 is 13 where will you be I
know I'm just 23rd oh um will I be on oh
I may be up my honeymoon or at the
Rascal Flatts concert you'll be at the
Rascal Flatts concert yeah yeah yeah I'm
so excited oh that's good we'll go to
the Rascal Flatts concert be on a high
show drunk get back from Camden New
Jersey it'll be midnight we'll be on our
party bus probably it comes out the
night before oh oh yeah it's like
Tuesday night yeah yeah Saturday night
whoa wait you guys hear that it's Taylor
do you guys think I'm gonna get to the
reputation ah I'm so pumped and it's
gonna be cutting out the leather through
the the lovers land the lovers lair
Lovers Lane that's key we have to talk
about Katy Perry oh right uh and like
literally actually tears my eyes I was
so happy for a school I've just been
like really loving Katy Perry lately I
choose back to the normal Katy Perry
that I found loveth and the first
concert I ever went to was Katy Perry at
Irving Plaza with her album hot and cold
no yeah what was up album called one of
the boys just for the boys something
like that I'm like I was thinking pre
merely an OG Taylor Swift
sorry a real OG Katy Perry fan like me
and Alex was out in the first row like
it was first concert we ever went to it
I didn't tell mom that it was GI because
I did she want to let me go and like it
was really an amazing concert and I was
just like dying I'm like she had the
cupcakes on her tits like it was premium
as hell and now like I feel like I can
be back to that Katy Perry stand ship
because hurts all the way she's
promoting Taylor's video I was like so
nice and so like women supporting women
like she did to link in her stories
posted it on her feed like just you know
premium asks friendship and then
just like do you think she filmed the
mikela do you think this was filmed
before after the mikela after so you
think she just had the outfit yes and I
think that that came about from her Met
Gala look I think this was post Matt
gala for sure okay I thought it might
have been before actually it's too far
out you know yeah yeah yeah even though
yeah yeah yeah okay um so then just like
Deb hanging out hugging kissing was so
cute here for it totally and then also
the pop queen pageant with RuPaul who
threw the crib crown in there yeah great
message for so I had this having the
hardest time figuring out who was who oh
I figure I they talk to the most obscure
office I thought Lady Gaga with SIA oh
that's a good one and I didn't know that
read Katy Perry outfit really that well
I wore the pink Nicki Minaj one the most
obvious one was already be an
intelectual it's it and she was very
like a smock and I was really having a
hard time figuring out who the punk yeah
also know by the way the Taylor one was
so good and the Ariana one at the end
was so obvious yeah but now I'm feeling
like who to daily out leave a like where
was Rihanna
but Rihanna hasn't put out music
literally in five years like if they
were gonna put out a Rihanna look it
would have to be from 2012 ya know and
honestly a bit at the pop scale right
now like Rihanna's not on okay whereas
Halsey really hold you on the same
stages that she wanted to get every
single singer up there like she just she
just plucked a feat oh I wouldn't
consider Halsey to Beyonce but I loved
thinking about it like I think with ho
Z's next album like she will be icon
status
she's number one in every category and
in every country and that that's a good
call where was pink there we go no but
also the thing about Halsey is that her
in the BTS song like it's taken her to
another level globally like I saw a
video I follow her hair stylist on
Instagram and they were she showed up at
a BTS concert and you should have seen
I've never seen a stadium so big in my
life I don't know where it was but it
was bigger than MetLife it was bigger
than any stadium I ever saw no she's
really like cement she's coming in and
she's gonna be you know up there on that
stage in the next video well I think
that's a great call thank you and
holding it like stands Taylor so I
understand Halsey right any additional
thoughts ah
had something to say about the Katy
Perry thing of it oh oh but what's
interesting is number when Katy Perry
said like she was gonna start making
purpose they'll pop and then she put out
like bone Appetit and yes legislation it
was just like you're not purposeful and
then feel as though Taylor Swift is
really making purposeful pop yeah and so
it's really apt that now Katy Perry is
coming in and it's like this is how it's
done my friend and on Taylor Swift's
livestream she said this was gonna be
her biggest album ever in terms of songs
like maybe that leaves room for more
collaborations like maybe a purposeful
pop anthem with Katy Perry that could
take over the summer I don't know I
don't know what they would be like the
end of the summer true sad sad
anyways exciting times it's always fun
together music video on a Monday and I
feel as though she understands the
treachery of the work life oh for sure
and so she did it for you know those
cogs and the machines out there it was
morning show hosts who needed something
to talk about who needed fodder for
their show yeah but some more fodder
Meghan King Edmonds on husband's affair
I don't trust him anymore okay over the
weekend it would came out that Jim
Edmonds had a salacious affair and while
nobody was really shocked
I guess Meghan King Edmonds was right
and it was literally like pretty much to
a tee what Kelly Don had said had
happened right and now I guess the
mistress you know she was a disgruntled
mistress and she gave all of her text to
all about the t.com oh that is so low
she couldn't even do like radar no
interested Meghan King Edmonds revealed
on her blog on Friday that she'll come
good on this [ __ ] for like taking his
moment and being thirsty and running
with it and taking like her ever unto
her blog I know she had a blog Meghan
King Edmonds his blog yeah I know yeah
no totally she revealed on her blog on
Friday that she found out about former
baseball star Jim's if they are in the
tabloids on Thursday when the story was
first published by all about the tea
calm and she confronted Jim on the phone
quote he confessed to me that he had
exchanged lewd photos with this woman
over the course of several months and a
physical relationship never existed no
paid her off to protect me so I'd never
found out yet Here I am writing about it
do I believe him she continued I don't
know because I don't trust him anymore
physical or not he's still had an affair
and he admits this to me
Jim later confessed to Us Weekly that he
had a lapse in judgment but a gun
insisted that he never made physical
contact with another woman this is
someone trying to profit from my name he
said in the statement I'm aware she has
done this to others in the past he added
that he wanted to pursue legal action
but it's not enough enough of an apology
for Meghan I'm a simple girl
wrote on her blog I wanted a solid
marriage I'm as loyal as they come and I
wanted the vows we made when we
exchanged our rings to be acted upon now
my wedding ring symbolizes fraud I
refuse to be humiliated by this marriage
is hard we've been through our ups and
downs I've talked about it openly a
relationship takes two but it doesn't
take two to cheat that's true okay I
mean this story is so crazy cuz it was a
very public he was literally sending
dick pics while his wife was in the
hospital giving birth to twins
oh no not twins no twins twins oh did
she get pregnant again yeah she now has
three Bettis oh good for her okay I
don't at the end of the day she got what
she wanted and [ __ ] Jim Edmonds [ __ ] Jim
Edmonds I don't believe him because also
I don't believe in me everything
mistress has said so far it's true
okay so she doesn't have like physical
proof that they met physical but why
would she make more up when she has the
yeah if you haven't if you have a truth
like that's good enough and you don't
need to make up lies in addition to it
right so I believe that he's still lying
he's a dirty [ __ ] dog I really can't
[ __ ] stand him but I read like a
really insightful comment like on some
Instagram that someone was so shocked by
this because like when Megan was on OC
like she was a lot of things but she was
very in tune like she called that
Brookes thing like she's always been
very like an investigator I don't know
what hold on but the right word is like
it starts with an i she's always been
very intuitive intuitive yes I was gonna
say interpretive and I knew that wasn't
right she's always been very intuitive
and like not that I think she knew about
it but I think maybe in some ways she
like turned a blind eye because she's
always been this like really smart
intuitive person and she called that
Brooke saying like she's just calling
people out left and right and now it's
her yeah I feel as though this isn't
like such a shock even when you would
see them on the show like he wasn't
excited to have a baby that he was so
rude he was really terrible and
unfortunately there is this stigma in
the sports world that like men can just
do what they want and oh my god you know
I've just rewatched Entourage and Jim
Edmonds was in an episode well it's like
they're out of private sending dick pics
they're at a private like a
aviation terminal and they're like with
Mark Wahlberg and like passing by with a
bunch of athletes and gentleman says I
go broke Jim what oh oh yes
somebody yeah he isn't somebody well I
just feel as though like there is this
you know sort of environment in the
environment and for Megan maybe she knew
maybe she didn't know but it's like look
it's like Chloe and Tristan it's like do
whatever you want but don't [ __ ]
embarrass me yeah don't leave traces
don't send dick pics to this mistress
who's literally like the I don't want to
call her a mean word but she's like the
mistress of Babylon in the basketball
community you think that she's gonna
like not be discreet if you're gonna
vacuum discreet that's a good call like
if you don't embarrass me right stay
good on Megan for being like I refuse to
be humiliated by this I didn't do
anything why is it embarrassing for her
no exactly so I think it's it's that
sort of situation where you never know
what goes on behind closed doors people
do weird things he's definitely a weird
dude but like be smart you know you're a
very prestigious guy I could just be
like texting with anyone [ __ ] Jeff
Bezos oh my god I was literally about to
say that too it's like please I mean but
you know what at the end of the day if
you have to be humiliated by your
husband gets 16 billion dollars in
return you know I think I'm okay with
that Meghan King Edmonds isn't good I
think the Jeff Bezos thing is way more
humiliating for him Jeff for those text
messages for his wife because they were
already like divorcing and now it's like
though and he's still with this [ __ ]
woman who leaked his share you know it's
way more a matter sing for him I mean
those text messages were so embarrassing
and people like me posted them
everywhere so he should be embarrassed
and like he knows that I mean I've been
watching McNamara so you know the
government's always watching Mark
Zuckerberg is watching and he knows that
like you have the ability to watch over
people so and so what is he doing
sending photos of his we also Spencer
Lane just made a great point I'm really
glad that Megan didn't blame the other
woman like I feel like a lot of times
when this happens I you go after the
mistress and like yes mistress was wrong
but like the husband was more wrong
because the mistress didn't have
anything to lose no I totally agree but
it's like it's so why is the mistress
like giving all of this talk about the
team if she's worried about Megan like
let her know no she said she's worried
about Mike and she needed a paycheck
from all you think all about the tepees
I think maybe she could have gotten
$1,000 okay we see also got paid off
eight amendments to not also did you
know I read on Instagram yesterday that
when he was in high school Spencer Pratt
sold a picture of the Olsen twins for
$50,000 to
some publication they went to the same
high school I heard I saw that some the
other day I didn't know that just like
an interesting factoid that I found to
be well interesting that's my favorite
kind of factoid meet you I mean there's
nothing like an interesting factoid okay
are you ready for our next story
yes bella thorne posts nude photos on
Twitter in retaliation against alleged
hacker
I saw them well she should be proud I
didn't see them because I don't look at
somebody nude photos no but they're not
nude she really said were so yeah but it
was like because she was being
threatened yeah
Bella Thorne is taking her power back
and in a bold way she tweeted a message
the other day yesterday as you all know
my [ __ ] was hacked for the last 24 hours
I'd been threatened with my own nudes
and I feel gross I feel watched I feel
someone has taken something from me that
i only wanted one special person to see
this stars message began but despite
feeling violated Thorne made it clear
that she was not going to let the
hackers actions face her for too long I
let a man take advantage of me over and
over and I'm [ __ ] sick of it I'm
putting this out because it's my
decision now you don't get to take
another thing away from me
uhhh and so she posted her own news that
the hacker was threatening to pose and
she posted screenshots of the text
messages with a hacker like being a
freak from an Android and I just have to
say this is my favorite thing
celebrities have been doing recently is
releasing their own nudes or something
like when Raven posted that disgusting
email she got from in touching me yeah
doctor who says you got tits done is it
true yeah you have until 11:00 a.m. to
respond Sarah Jessica Parker did that
about like they were saying her and her
husband were fighting an arrest oh yeah
and when Kim did her selfie book and
like the week before it went into print
someone was threatening her iCloud got
hacked and in her selfie book she
included for the nudes that got hacked
yeah and she looked great or like when
Amanda Stanton was being right yeah with
her medical and she just came out it was
like if you're getting my nudes sorry
crazy yeah so yeah I agree it's such an
empowering move I love it it really is
it's just like so disappointing that
like we still live in a time where
people are being hacked like I have
really started to realize like that
nothing is private like I won't even
check something secretive like I get
nervous I'll only say it yeah sometimes
I get like so weird my attacks on and
Instagram DMS yes like if like snitch
always says like shell DM
something like shady about someone and
they don't respond because like I don't
say and like we could talk about it when
I see you
so I'm [ __ ] yes pretty much pretty
much okay next story let me just breeze
him right through him today oh that's
true much to discuss much to get the
children how's the oh speaking of
children he's great actually I loved him
in the crate today because he was all
muddy from his pocket and I'm time to
give him a bath but he's just precious
he really needs a haircut but other than
that he's just you know making lives
better did he miss mummy he did I mean
when he saw me crying like I could have
died like F between the father save it
all the Taylor Swift box and then the
reunion with the ocean yesterday like I
cried maybe four times it is a crowd on
the plane like I just couldn't cry same
you did yes what Jackie what I turned
are you crying
yes my eyes were watery gonna call you
that speaking about Father's Day I
wanted to it for a picture of me and
daddy in like the second I saw it like I
just cried oh wait I saw your freaking
post I was listening to even though I'm
leaving and that's really what's what's
just make me emotional like all the time
even on a plane we should have like
cried together probably no he didn't
talk about it like that is so funny I'm
crying now that's so spooky Wow I slept
really well it takes me CBD like it was
a great day yeah I took some CBD for the
plane
oh is that ready fell asleep well I was
sleepy because I'm in sleep at all the
night before cuz you gave me that to
defend D what D keeps you up oh the D
[ __ ] with you yeah it does so I knew I
was gonna be sick enemy than the CBD
just like relax me I was just being like
tense got a tense toaster of course you
know anyways speaking of Theo and a
really [ __ ] sad story wag dog walkers
stole couples gift
still couples dog to gift to someone
else say Court docs I saw and you know
what like I don't [ __ ] understand
this dogs are the most over bred species
in the world like if you wanted to get
someone a dog
you could literally get one for $1 at a
local shelter like why you stealing
someone else's you [ __ ] free no
[ __ ] freak this is such a crazy story
and like we all sort of watched it
unravel I saw in the toasters I saw it
like someone that I'm friends with they
reach out someone else's story so I
think I have like three degrees of
separation from this person okay who got
their dog stolen so I was just like
watching every update that Olivia that's
not in good on let me I'm on because if
it's terrible PR for wag wouldn't like
it wasn't their fault they just had a
[ __ ] loser like that they hired but
they got the dog back which is great but
weird and spooky and I having a news
wagon over a year just cuz I heard like
way too many sob stories that's so
upsetting like it's such a good idea
they have to take out but it's like uber
like any app that is really like it's
such a problem-solver like it's down to
have its issues yeah but I mean I'm just
like love Theo so much that I just I
don't know I freaks me out that would be
so sad I mean I would die like one time
a wag Walker's phone died and I had a
[ __ ] mental breakdown and I was
literally running around town like a
chicken with my head cut off screaming
at everyone and then she just showed up
back at my door like I was like okay
unacceptable unacceptable there's this
episode of Black Mirror that has to do
with like uber or it's they called it
something else where the driver like
kidnaps someone so show me be a manager
well he wanted to it was like someone
who worked at Facebook but it was called
squiggle or something huh and because he
kidnapped the person because he wanted
to get the Mark Zuckerberg attention oh
and so he came to him and he was like
get me Billy Bob on the phone a
McFarlane here what was it Billy I
forgot and like I'm just an intern and
he was like yeah and it was a good
episode and there was less spooky than
they've been okay big the final story
before we talk all things TV OJ Simpson
joins Twitter quote I gotta get a little
getting even to do Oh Jay Simpson
monster whatever happened the last time
you got even OJ you ended up in jail two
people died well he didn't end up in
jail for that no but you know you did
end up in jail and two people did die Oh
Jay Simpson launched a Twitter account
with video post in which the former
football star said he's got a little
getting even today
simpson confirmed the new account to the
AP on saturday seeing in the phone
interview while on a las vegas golf
course that quote it will be a lot of
fun
can you imagine is being like a
journalist for whatever publication that
was AP the AP and then just like ending
up on the phone with OJ Simpson quote AP
is Evo the AP blackmail playing again
they're [ __ ] able I've got some things
to straighten out he said he did not
elaborate before he said he had to go
and undid the call through 11:00 p.m.
Eastern Time sunday Simpson had more
than half a million followers on Twitter
Simpson is generally kept a low profile
since his released from prison in
October 2017 for robbery and kidnapping
over an attempt to steal back some of
his sports memorabilia from a Las Vegas
hotel room okay so this is interesante I
mean it seems like a logical fit next
step for a free man
yeah but um been made a great call like
how do you think he knew what Twitter
was like when do you because he's been a
private prison for so long before he
went in there was like barely cellphones
and now that he's come out it's like
fully the digital age and it's the
digital diaspora so how do you think G
Simpson found out about Twitter do you
think they explained to him when he got
out or he knew about it when he was in
mmm I think he probably found out about
it while he was in you know they brought
some news sometimes that's what I said
too bad it was Twitter makes the news
you know I think it he had heard of it
he must have it a social media intern
because like when you've really you've
been in jail a lot of time now to get
reactivated to all this new technology I
don't know it's like he's it's 20 years
of new technology it for an older person
like it couldn't be hard for him to
adapt well Twitter's pretty basic
yeah I don't want to see him on snapchat
anytime soon no and I don't think he'll
be on tik-tok anytime soon yeah also on
Kardashians were they were talking about
Courtney's ad cleaner sushi dyeing that
was somebody I thought to myself she
said sushi so weird and then Scott was a
sushi okay let's talk about keeping up
with Kardashians because but before we
talk about Keeping Up with the
Kardashians I really feel like you
shouldn't have to choose between
overpriced designer sunglasses and cheap
shades that won't last until summer
that's why we'll never wear anything
other than movement and the empty
sunglasses you've heard us talk about
movement disrupting the watch industry
well now they're doing it again with
sunglasses the LA based accessories
brand has hundreds of premium affordable
sunglasses to choose from so whether
you're into more timeless shapes like
classic round Sonny's or something that
makes a statement like fund I need fun
90s skinny frames they've got them all
constructed with durable acetate and
lightweight materials for that perfect
reliable fit you don't have to choose
between style and function you get both
movement sunglasses start at $60 and no
pair are priced over $95 so you're
guaranteed to find a style that you
loved with quality that doesn't break
the bank they've sold over two and a
half million products across more than
160 countries and their collections are
always expanding so get 15% off today
with free shipping and free returns by
going to movement comm slash toast
that's MVM t.com slash toast see my
movement keeps growing check out their
expanding collection if you go to
movement MBM t.com slash toast that's
MVM t.com slash TOA st join the movement
we just have the cutest sunglasses yeah
mine are super cute I think we got the
same pair yeah but I got them in blue
but I got them first no but like we got
them at the same time no but like I
responded to the email first oh for sure
but then when I respond and then I saw
that we asked for the same pair they
were just obvious it's like go to move
in time slash shows you'll know exactly
which one's the guy yeah actually they
should that's a recall okay
Kardashians is that where we want to
start I think so it's type of mine for
me I watched you last night meet you
yesterday's and I caught up on just the
whole season and okay Lee is kind of
good like I had found that they're
opening up a little bit more it used to
be so boring where I was like there was
something kind of interesting and then
three subplots uh-huh now the subplots
are really subplots like MJ and
talentless and Scott but that was an
interesting sub ah yeah that's what I
really felt like talentless came out of
nowhere and then all the time they
started ripping it up and it's because
Kris Jenner inspired Scott to do that
yeah but last night's episode was wildly
interesting because I I do remember
seeing that Courtney went on this trip
with Kendall and her friends and was
like hanging out with Kendall's friends
for like two weeks straight and how
[ __ ] weird it was and now I know that
it was weird yeah and I'm glad Kendall
was annoyed and she would have been it
even if Courtney wasn't being a [ __ ]
like her older sister hanging out with
her friends and going on trips is weird
and she should have been annoyed anyway
and then Courtney being like such a
loser like being mean to Kendall just to
make her friends think she's funny like
I could die that's solely putting her
legs up like that's like so if not just
like that's what you do in high school
like to be like
yeah it was just like the lowest common
denominator level of humor and Cortney
being like I need jokes I'm just funny
like me I'm cooler and funnier the least
funny person I've ever seen on my
television show like and truly the least
interesting to like that truly and then
they plunge Chloe right I did not think
Chloe was meddling and I thought it was
actually really mature of Chloe to like
take what Kendall said and tell Courtney
cause Courtney should know she's a
[ __ ] 40 year old woman like she
should know she's a mama she three
hurting her 20 year old sister and her
feelings are hurt yeah right
I think Chloe was wrong at all obviously
first of all this was a storyline so
someone had to Courtney had to find out
what skit what cannibal saying and
Kendall had to find out what Kourtney
was saying cuz this is a [ __ ] TV show
and that's just the job that Chloe got
and then they blamed it on her yeah [ __ ]
dad wasn't her fault really gave good
insight I feel like out of all them like
obviously I like Courtney at least but I
feel like I don't really get along with
Kendall the least because like she's
just so not my bod like no when I just
let me get little snippets like she
really films like not that much I can't
like Kylie a little more than Kylie but
when we get like sneaks into her life
I'm like damn like I would never hang
out with her like her I do have a good
time it's like having her friends over
for a home-cooked meal like you're 21 go
to a club no totally early yeah man we
forgot the episode where she went
where's my grant you know Jen Mackin
because she was like in Paris yeah
[ __ ] camp that was like Cooper first
episode the worst storyline that they
ever conceived and you know I found the
Kiley office drama to be wildly
interesting but then wait when when
Chris got on the phone to like that with
someone and she chose corny and it's
like Kylie billionaire Jenner like how
jealous are in you Courtney like I could
die a hundred words I thought everything
was fake about that storyline except
like then they called Courtney and she
took it seriously was really saying how
she felt it whoa relax like it's just a
storyline because that was all so dumb
like being in the middle of the
conference room like no no so I may not
know whose office it is no totally and
it's a huge [ __ ] office I get another
one but the fact that Chris gave
Kourtney and Scott Khloe and Scott a
tour making it she never said it was a
Kylie cosmetics
seeing you like it was [ __ ] Chris's
new office that was crazy
like I don't understand how things like
this happened like you each all have
condos that you work out of Kylie is
building enough whose name is on the
office like it should be Ellie wasn't
done yet so Kylie said that her logo
wasn't there yet
like when they registered for the office
building like who write like you
probably Kylie cosmetics LLC but I think
Kris Jenner is like the CFO of Kylie
cosmetics like yeah I think Kris Jenner
makes a lot of money and works like
almost full-time on colleagues highly
still CEO you know totally but so Kris
being like I want to share an office
with the CEO is not that far-fetched
because they're both for sports our
daughter and they're both so high up in
the company I think Christian Chrisman
CFO and CEO Sharon Ausmus but what CEO
and CFO our daughter and mother no but
like Kris doesn't like people take phone
calls she has kids and dogs like there's
more than enough space for two offices
no there's more than enough space for
sure but like Kris just wants to be
included like you know what I mean
Kris is like kind of pathetic and every
time I watch episodes of the Kardashians
like I really feel like Chris is my
favorite and that if I was in their
family like I would latch on to Chris I
love Chris she'sshe's great I felt at
like everything about that she was going
to tour tribes this is my photo studio
just Kris Jenner - she was like it was
contrived in that Ben got really really
fake to me okay so that was annoying
because there's enough to go off of yeah
I could've talked about mammoth more
tell me about these potatoes you know
one of them and there was also the Kim
psoriasis thing that they shoved into a
flashback because they they film so much
content of her going on all those
different like doctors and then they
didn't even make it a storyline they
literally showed a clip of it like like
a flashback yeah that was also
interesting and we came out at the same
week that her body makeup is coming out
but she announced and I just want to say
like I've never needed anything so much
in my life same and you know what was so
funny as well she was like talking about
how she wasn't gonna go out her she was
gonna wear this outfit B that's a first
I thought to myself I'm like you know I
really wish she just like embraced it
more cuz I get the cheese like shallow
and it's like funny and she like loves
the way that she looks but like it would
be really empowering if she just like
kind of owned her psoriasis and went out
with a big psoriasis patch on her leg
once and then towards the end of the
episode I kind of came to that
conclusion like working with Whitney
Harlow and I was just so proud of her
because I was like getting annoyed with
her I'm like who cares you're like the
most beautiful wilmore in the world
you'd like a little scratch on you're
like just go no but I mean so much of
her job is her it would take a lot it
will take a lot for her to come to that
conclusion considering like the world
and society and even herself has just
made everything about her to be about
her looks you know you know totally and
that's what why would be so great but
she she's getting there III thought that
towards the end of the episode she
turned took a turn for sure but now she
to sell body makeup so she can't
actually take that turn yes I will be
buying it though this is something that
I've needed like one of the shades
there's a bunch of cheese and it looks
looks like I'm actually looks like maybe
there's four shades that's not enough
you think yeah why it's like four women
of the women of the world fair medium
dark
that's what Juergen that's what everyone
does their needs see more it took
foundation for your legs and let's
tension lines have like 30 lines they're
like oh your face it needs to match
perfectly for your legs you just want
can't like everyone just wants tan shiny
legs I don't know I'll see I might have
to buy two shades I'll be buying it in
spades me too and I feel like this is
what she should have been doing from the
beginning that I agree when she comes
out with like a lip kit I'm like okay
I've seen this before but this is
ingenious this is so her and it everyone
says she's been doing it for years
yeah that's a great call but k'kaw booty
really should have been more of like
like a body like a body foundations body
glow body shimmer body glitter like yeah
cuz she's like known for her body like
and her glam to but glam is taken care
of by Kylie she could have done more of
like a Jergens brand yeah well she's
standing in tonight now and I'm very
much here for it and I will be setting
an alarm for this one actually I wonder
like no way else inside set in the law
how it'll do in comparison to her other
launches I hope it does really well I
hope so too
I'm sure boom me too okay next step
brownie
oh my god what a great episode I was so
mad to have missed this show because so
much happened so much needed to be
recapped but at the end of the day I'm
here for Sonja Morgan and that's really
what I got out of this episode and you
know what like good on her I really I I
say this so confidently I do not think
Sonja Morgan has a drinking problem
but I do think she's really aware of how
she comes off in the show and when all
the ladies even Bethenny was like you
should go to the meeting if she
protested she would have looked like she
had a problem yeah she was really smart
she was like sure I'll go whatever I'll
go support levant and I totally
understand why she had a [ __ ] break
down afterwards and the win is such a
[ __ ] because LuAnn was like you were
fine in the car no she wasn't she was
trying to talk to you you were just on
your phone like so self-involved in your
tabare then you couldn't think of
anything else she didn't just turn like
in a second and when she got to ask less
she was having a breakdown it started in
the car yeah like she was still busy
we shook by what she heard and I totally
get that I feel as though she's a very
compassionate person like LuAnn is
talking these people sharing her story
making them laugh whenever making it
about her I'm sure and then she's going
back to their mansion on the beach
probably that it's like when other
people share in a I can't imagine that
LuAnn is listening with both ears wide
open she's in her own world no exactly
so he sat there and was just like it's
so sad and she said how can I go back to
like this lavish whatever and I'm
hearing what people who are like living
on the streets due to their addiction
like it's sad yeah and they're gonna go
sleep on the beach and we are going back
to this house like and have you just
LuAnn I'm gonna get drunk jump right and
then just the whole thing but then it
really culminated at dinner then first
of all I love Barbara when she's turned
to crying in the in the she started out
to Jay on my bad side like when she was
crying in the kitchen I'm like [ __ ] get
it the [ __ ] together better than to give
her some great advice and then she took
it and she really made more of an effort
with the girls and you know what it's
like to be on a trip with people and
she's like just thrown into this group
of women and LuAnn is really her life
raft and Luanne it's not helpful at all
so it can't be see the crying she took
it too far but she really took
Bethenny's advice really well and the
women are starting to warm up at her and
I'm really and I'm glad about it and
she's being really like she turned on a
dime on LuAnn but at the beginning of
the day I was like no sis you gotta go
home like I was really not here for her
at all yeah no I mean nothing unites
women like talking [ __ ] about Ana that
woman so true but it wasn't even the
fact that they needed her to talk she
about Lynne it's like they needed her to
admit that Luann's been a bad friend to
her know that she didn't stop kissing
her ass right that she's only on this
trip because of the land and then
Luann's not there for her yet she
admitted and that's fine
yeah um the dinner the dinner first of
all Barton G's it's an iconic Miami
restaurant where I went when I was in
high school and I saw Brooke Hogan and
we took a picture together Wow on a
blackberry as if it's me is anymore
history right then Bethenny had a
full-blown panic
overdub and LuAnn and missed her panic
attack she delivered she's dropped like
the most interesting Easter eggs
I got you rehab for free interesting
factoids that were unbelievably
interesting negligee in the field
negligee in the field Dennis you got
something else happened where she got
arrested or something and Dennis made
sure that it never made her record or
never became public she tries to get in
the car and travel she was drunk
definitely I just sit outside her house
so she wouldn't get in her car
literally killed her so he had to talk
to her children yeah like so many and
she that wasn't even the point of
deputies breakdown it just literally
like slipped out and it was wildly
interesting and I knew a decent amount I
knew that
Dennis was really involved in her Palm
Beach scandal because he's like works
with lawyers and he just like has a lot
of clout in Palm Beach and he was super
helpful but I didn't know the extent of
it all no not at all and I understood
what Bethenny was saying and I feel as
though she'd ever even realized it
before but it's like all that time she
spent interventioning for LuAnn she
could have spent doing that for doing
that for Dennis yeah maybe things would
have been different you know like when
she kept saying I took and I don't think
LuAnn still gets it to this case no I
was doing an intervention for you while
my fiancee died of a drug overdose yeah
do not see how those things are
connected and how I could possibly be
affected and you don't give a [ __ ] yeah
or even ask how I'm doing like even
regardless of the addiction think it's
like Bethany screaming and all the way I
can talk about is her cabaret show it
said what are you check on your friend
who also happened to help you and save
their life a million times no I don't
think that they talked about it so
little that I actually forgot that about
me too they talk about that in so little
so close you know like it's only been a
few months so and then Luann's just
response to everyone was pure evil like
her beau by the way there was a time
where I hated LuAnn so much it was when
Bethenny first started dating Dennis and
she's like you're married dating a
married man you're [ __ ] separated
she's been separated for years I an that
reunion made me really like in my soul
like really hate LuAnn so much and then
I just started loving her like class
with the countess cabaret like icon
status love her so much and now I'm back
to that lion place because les last
week's episode was so horrible because
she bit the hand and I said her and then
the way that LuAnn oh definitely a debt
of gratitude that can never be repaid
and just baseline just means be nice to
her be supportive of her don't talk [ __ ]
about her is the way that Bethenny Oh
Sonja that same daddy shoe from last
season and if Bethenny were to ever turn
on Sonja like LuAnn is just her not
Metheny yeah I would be out on Bethenny
- yep that's such a great she would
never do that because she understands
how the world works
and what's so interesting is talking
about last season is I really realized
this week how Carol made so many of the
women so ugly in my eyes like
I loathe the Dorinda last year
I'm loving her this year she's soaked
lucid she's on the right side of history
she's not getting too involved loving
her
Tinsley I was like really hating last
year unless she's dumb an immature
that's totally what I thought now I love
her she's so cute when she was drunk and
fighting for Bethenny loved her she was
having the best time on her date she
kissed him like I was really living fur
and it's just so funny how those two
characters were so blinked too careless
here and I hated them so much and now I
love them I never hate I mean - it's so
funny concern is still like half the
time she's right and half the time she's
not gonna I don't know what the
difference is like maybe it's the
Carroll difference I don't know maybe
now that she's turned she'll stay I've
always liked Tinsley but it was getting
to be really annoying that like
immaturity you know the dependency and
Bethenny really whips her into shape
like Carole was her enabler and Bethenny
said go on a date she literally got her
dress at my foot her diaper on it sent
her out the door for the no date and
then when Beth when they met up at the
restaurant in simply Bethenny was like
how did it go and it was great like and
Bethenny was so genuinely happy together
it and they woke up in the same bed for
the second day a second time it felt
like true friends like that's how I
would feel if I sent my friend up on a
dating like it went well it's like just
so exciting ya know I'm so here for that
friendship we need to talk about the
rumors page six is now who written two
articles that Tinsley is in danger of
being kicked off the show that she's
filming testings with like younger
prominent women to like bring some clout
to the show meanwhile Bravo is courting
Anthony Skye removed she's wife now I'm
gonna go ahead and say on the record I
think that this is all fake news
definitely the scare Meucci is this is
the first time that I've heard that
Anthony scared when she's wife wants to
be on the show and the what first time I
heard it I'm pretty sure was her saying
I want to be on the show and now it's
saying I can't say yeah I know she's a
thirst matcher
Bravo really quartz anyone especially
not her who is midcourt like Denise
Richards a coarse [ __ ] Kathy Hilton
and Kris Jenner yeah oh my god Jen if
Kris Jenner was on Real Housewives of
Beverly Hills
that would be iconic and she is the Real
Housewives of Beverly she's the
housewife the realest
that's what when Erika Jayne was on
justice it with Justin Sylvester he was
like who's your dream cast member she
was like Kris Jenner and she's so right
for a million reasons yeah no like
that's I feel like we're headed that way
meeting yeah that'll make your times us
closer like Kris Jenner will
tire on Real Housewives of Beverly Hills
yeah that's a great call you know what I
mean and it's like the e NBCUniversal
Bravo integration synergy Kathy Hilton
would be the next logical step and yes
mrs. skur Moochie I don't even know her
first name I don't know that anyone's
really clamoring for her also Tinsley is
more interesting and more involved than
she's ever been
why was the youngest one like she's so
cute she really brings like a new fresh
life to the show she does and she has
she's the only really like single one
who's still interested in having
children yeah it's just a different vibe
yes she can be annoying but I think
she's coming around like this wouldn't
be the time to cut her off no I agree if
it would have been last year they were
saying they're filming test scenes that
makes no sense they're not filming right
now
Brava doesn't just make test scenes no
it's weird
I don't I don't believe any of the
rumors honestly right I think but I have
heard rumors that some of the really
og's are on the chopping block like
Ramona and honestly that I would believe
I just think even though when I was like
they really got bowls in like they'll
keep Ramona biggie almost at his most
dry stale piece of bread ever but she's
the og housewife right Ramona's the only
og New Yorker that's true
even though like she is technically but
like LuAnn is super og so was Bethenny
LuAnn became friend and Bethenny laughs
and Ramona is the only one who's been
there awesome no I know but let's she
they're still oh geez right but like
technically sure Ramona this show would
be the show without Ramona well it was a
motive so funny and she brings so much
strong without even trying she doesn't
have to be Lisa Vanderpump
she's been intentionally quiet this
season but she's still great she's still
like and sometimes like I love her and
sometimes I don't understand what she's
doing or why she's doing it but it's
great television regardless yeah no it
was a great episode like even nothing
has been really been happening on their
trip like I just enjoy these ladies a
lot see and I feel as though the cast
right now really works I wouldn't change
anything
I mean hey Barbara look I'm getting
interested by Barbara or I'm not if they
want to see over to Barbara they could
bring in someone who has me someone was
it an established history with a lot of
the women you know yeah like Missy yeah
or even an old I mean Jill Zarin I
wonder why they never bring her back
because she's dying to be on I know but
they definitely could use a bump and it
would really it would I feel like
Bethenny would walk you say yeah I think
maybe in her contract somewhere like she
gets to leave because like I don't think
that's what Bethenny wants to be known
for that's what she was known
for so long I agree I'm just okay that
would be a reason why they don't bring
her back when I'm just sayin I I feel
like they could bring someone back who's
already been on this ship Cindy Barshop
or like Kelly Bensimon Kelly hey Heather
I'd like tether me too and she was like
strong and I feel you know she stands up
like you can drama doesn't just happen
out of nowhere but you also don't want
people who are just saying things like
Camille to start agree start so if
someone feels really strongly about
something like when someone's you know
true to their convictions they're gonna
speak their mind and then that starts
conflict yeah like Bethenny yeah and
that's good
yeah I agree so I think honestly this
episode of New York was one of the
greatest episodes of housewives ever had
in years and I just I'm so team Bethenny
Sonja tensely during that Ramona meet
you that I can't see and like you know
me too and they were just like having
lunch eating crab cakes oh so funny like
that thing was making them all mom and
when LuAnn made fun of Tinsley for
slurring oh my god I mean like how could
you
my bad myself that like last year I
really went to bat for the win like even
when she was in rehab and all the ladies
were making fun of like her sobriety
being fake I was like how dare you but
like sorry her sobriety is fake and like
I am mad at myself for just like being
such a LuAnn Stan because like a loose
tan because she doesn't deserve it she
doesn't have my sis attitude no but I'm
not mad at any of us were having her
side first well she was trying to better
herself we all you have to give someone
at least one chance yeah homie once
shame on you fool me twice shame on me
so now I'm out okay but shame on you for
fooling me once exactly as you did I was
for Beverly Hills Beverly Hills what's
the weirdest episode ever because I was
ready for it to be like a kumbaya kind
of like how in New York how mostly
everyone's getting along it's like you
enjoy that as much as you enjoy the
fighting and whatever the [ __ ] Kyle and
Teddy aren't doing like it's really
weird and the fact that they don't drop
it next episode where they're like I
feel you don't wanna hang out with us
that's at least Vanderpump sounds like
why did what are they doing I don't know
I it's they're all in a really weird
place because on the one hand they have
to prove that without Lisa Vanderpump
they all get along and everyone's nice
on the other hand they have to prove
that without Lisa Vanderpump the show is
still buzzing yeah so I understand where
it's all coming from and they want to
have this like come and they were gonna
they were gonna put that on Camille
but then Camille's house Berg down till
they they can't go yelling at her cuz
that's [ __ ] evil yeah so now they're
trying to figure out a way to make this
trip combative
there'd be some sort of fight and they
don't know what to do and it's like it's
like Kyle and Teddy decided in their
rooms separately that it's gonna be on
Erika Erika and Lisa it's really weird I
mean there was a better way to go about
it like really open at the end of the
day they were arguing on Erika's behalf
and Erika wasn't mad and she was like
stop trying to bait me into this
conversation and it was the best
response ever it was so weird and then
Teddy doesn't know to say she's like I
mean I guess he just feel like don't
understand Erika Jayne the person it's a
shot oh it was so nice she was like stop
it's like finally they got to a point
where Eric was like I'm not mad like
don't get me into this conversation and
then Teddy said well maybe the issue
then is that I don't understand her okay
I'm like could you explain it like an
actual preschool it was so weird it was
so stupid
Erika shut that [ __ ] down and I thought
you successfully shove it down anyone
had a bone to pick it was Kyle Lisa
Rinna had nothing saying nothing to with
Erika she could have said you made me
uncomfortable at my party by calling my
sister and nothing to do with the fact
that she was just like Erika Jayne and
I'm trying to make Erika mad at Lisa
whenever couldn't least our best friends
even if it wasn't her best friend I
don't think Erika's the type of person
to get mad at something like that also
if Erika was mad at Lisa bout it she
would have talked her about there's such
good friends she would have talked her
about it like off camera or just a loan
they would have squashed it and move
forward yeah but Erika is also not a
loser like that till I get so upset
about something that's not even a big
deal no it was hilarious no it was
hilarious Teddy and Kyle are like
freaking me out and honestly like I'm
afraid to say it's like it's really
making me just question like them
totally it's not it's just not a good
look that like Teddy's being Kyle's
henchwoman um when tecnique like that
was with Jews they were accusing Lisa
Vanderpump of using people to do you
know and now they're just doing it with
yeah you know yeah oh so the most
interesting part of the episode was the
DIY glam yeah and who brought it and who
did not agree do we continues to impress
me first of all I like her hair better
when she does it herself because she all
she can do is curl and obviously and it
looks great and there's no crazy bobby
pins it looks great no but I it was nice
to see what she can do on her own and
like her just like looking like a
regular guy where's my Glen list just
for Provence because it's different than
usual
it goes to read Lisa Rinna
Erika Kyle Teddy oh I disagree
der eat
Kyle Kyle's great of her hair and me
yeah oh I'll show you my outfit sorry
I'm sorry I wasn't talking on here
makeup I'm talking about like a full
looks oh they're all really putting
together looks okay jury and then like
everyone else is here yeah like Lisa
Rinna Kyle for me are the same Teddy um
is looking great but every time they cut
to that testimonial with the bangs like
I just can't the bangs are so bad then
like I feel it so she looked that way
the whole episode I can't like get it
out of my head yeah and then Erica is
interesting because you see how much she
relies on her glam team because here
she's really just wearing like all black
cool boots new jackets um great hats
long hair she's doing like them the most
while actually to mean am absolutely
psyche I don't think she washed her hair
once in every bonds which I respect I
haven't washed my hair since before our
trip yeah it's not crazy why I got my
hair done on Wednesday before our trip I
worked down for a few days and then once
I put it up into a bun and we were
getting massages I'm gonna wash it after
SoulCycle today which Claudia is coming
to yes am I just like really haven't
stopped eating and I think it's time so
I respected Erika's like approach and I
loved it like the over hi sending jacket
oh my god jacket was amazing yeah but
when they're at dinner and she's like so
bored by their conversation she's really
wearing like a track like a sweatshirt
and sweatpants yeah she looks like she's
gonna sleep right when everyone else was
was doing more that house is amazing I
need to go like the land I could die I
could die I've never wanted to go to
Provence before no me neither
i me the [ __ ] up I want to go visit the
lavender fields of Provence for our next
field trip yeah thanks what else
southern charm
um you know what I'm so bored by some
time I find myself scrolling my phone's
so much and I have a question is Dani a
full time cast member no this is the
most she's ever been involved her
filming with her mom that was so weird
yeah I think they're bringing her in but
she's been on since season morning never
been a cast member that's weird she's
like Marlo right I don't know if that's
Bravo's caller her call I don't know cuz
she's also never been thirsty about it
oh my god Craig inviting everyone over
to fill orders was so funny and Patricia
showing up to his house like that really
cemented for me in that moment I was
like this show is problematic because
why is this 80 year old woman hanging
out with a bunch of 20 year olds no it's
true it's very problematic I don't even
remember what happened I watched it like
so long yeah it was such like a it's
nothing nothing happened well recap it
when it's on this week exactly is that
all
yeah I think so I watched a great
Lifetime movie you did it oh my god yes
is called my husband's secret wife and
just had so many twists and turns I
really didn't know where it was gonna go
I highly recommend it
okay most good legs like hallmark
looking people all right and with like
murder mysteries murder mysteries
channel movies and mysteries nobody
don't like kill people and kidnap
children right so when I watched natin
live which episode the one last night I
watched like ten minutes I didn't watch
it it's not it it's not it's it's not it
I heard last night's episode was not it
and it's not it okay can you watch the
first episode yeah you think yeah but it
ain't it though cuz you need to be
introduced to everyone okay
no I got it the theme song really lays
it out for you this theme sounds really
good yeah and it's like Moon's brother
nuts feather lives dad loves that Muslim
loose episode and then you can be out Oh
Craig we're doing eyeliner that was
what's the [ __ ] was that
there are you looking for an island he's
like a ham I like that it looks that was
weird
um okay well Taylor Stokes best friend
has to go cuz she's like so busy today
gonna call Taylor doing Taylor's like
yeah
er yeah cool just like fighting in the
comment section on behalf of chatter I
got a lot of people to respond to really
what our heater saying um so the song
sucks
Taylor sucks she's exploiting the gay
community for corporate greed I don't
know nothing I can relate to thank you
guys for watching the morning show some
millennial morning show we go live
Monday through Friday 10:30 a.m. Eastern
Time on YouTube - make sure to subscribe
give this video a thumbs up also head
over to girl no job calm because I'm
going on thar Virginia Beach
Santiago die Virginia Beach San Diego
Richmond Charleston and Vegas this
summer so hit up girls on job Humbert
tickets um and then yes our podcasts are
also available our episodes are also
available as a podcast oh my god I can't
[ __ ] talk just subscribe to us on
itunes bye
wait follow me hijack ego problems get
my presets jackieo low calm bye
you